this is a century safe model ms0 100
it's fire resistant and has a dial lock
with a million possible combinations and
this is nathan seidle nathan are you a
safecracker not a safecracker but I
build a safe cracking robot last year
sidles wife gave him this already locked
safe as a gift no combination we would
present but Seidel loves a good
challenge so she knew I was really into
puzzles and locks and robotics and those
three came together and today we can
open safe SCYTL is an engineer who
started spark fun a small electronics
manufacturer so he decided to build a
robot to crack the safe we found two
exploits to take the key set domain from
a million possible combinations down to
about a thousand combinations the robot
has a dial spanner and a clever arm that
tries the door after each new
combination the electronics are
controlled by it's just an Arduino and
Arduino with a shield and the code kind
of reads feedback from the motor reads
all the different inputs there's a photo
gate that tells us where zero is and
there's some analog feedback on the
servo so we can tell when the handle has
been pulled down and the safe is open it
took a tremendous amount of code took a
lot of electronics but the 3d printing
ended up being sort of the crux piece
but even with his robot trying
combinations every 10 seconds cracking
the safe would take almost four months
but Seidel found a few shortcuts
including one meant to stop human
safecrackers the combination dial
indents so they put those indents there
to protect against the vulnerability of
the safe and by doing that they actually
introduced a new vulnerability Seidel
took a close look inside another sentry
safe he'd owned and he found that the
space between the notches of the correct
combination is ever so slightly smaller
about a hundredth of an inch narrower
and it turns out that the skinniest
indent is actually the last number of
the three numbers of the combination so
if we can measure those indents and we
can find the skinniest one the
we can find the third number of the
combination so instead of a million
combinations we've now reduced it pretty
significantly
so Seidel coded the robot to measure
that tiny difference and suddenly had
the last digit of the combination the
second exploit that we found is with
most safes there's some manufacturing
tolerances and so on are safe it turns
out that the the it the combination is
actually three digits wide so if the
number is 51 it turns out 50 or 52 will
work so instead of 100 times 100 times
100 it's 33 times 33 times 33 and
because we figured out that last digit
it's 33 times 33 times 1 so now we're
down to about a thousand combinations
the last exploit that we've figured out
is something we call set testing because
we have a robot and robots are really
good at knowing where they are set
testing is where it sets the dial to a
specific location tries the combination
and then goes back and adjusts one of
the dial and then goes back and tries
the next combination all that shaved the
time down dramatically now he can crack
the safe in about 15 minutes while this
hack does prove how easy it's becoming
to leverage inexpensive open-source
hardware and code to crack historically
dependable analog security systems
Seidel doesn't think anyone with a safe
like this should be worried as
open-source becomes more prevalent
people are looking into more things I'm
poking at this safe and I'm sort of
saying hey I found this thing
maybe maybe safe manufacturer you should
know about this so you can make safes
better that's sort of the mentality of
open-source so I think security in
general is going to get better the more
the community embraces open-source
because it's not about hey check out
what I can steal
it's about hey I found this thing and I
want to share it with you I want to
point out this issue so you can make
this more secure it came from Craigslist
and we weren't sure what was inside in
the end we got it open yay but there was
nothing inside
it's always a gamble Geraldo Rivera that
would would agree